AMY: OK.
Hi everyone, and welcome to
another App Engine Office
Hours Hangout.
And so, this is Amy from App
Engine Developer Relations,
once again happily
not on screen.
And joining me in our lovely
studio today are three members
of the App Engine team.
So these are Sam,
Brian, and Matt.
And they are going to talk to
us today about a really neat
thing that they've been working
on, which is a new,
experimental Dev App
Server for Python.
And so if you want to join
this Hangout, please do.
If anyone is watching,
you can go to the
developers.google.com/liveevent
page, and you should see a
Join button.
And you can also see
a Join link on our
cloud platform G+ page.
And this is, of course, being
recorded, as well.
OK, let's get started.
And I'll let these guys
take it away.
Brian, tell us a little bit
about what the new Dev App
Server is and what it's doing.
BRIAN: Well, I'll actually start
by pointing out how you
can get to it.
Because it's my goal here to try
and convince everyone who
listens to this that they should
download Dev App Server
to test us and provide feedback
so we can make it
better when we release it.
As always, the URL is
devappserver2 in a Google search.
And then click on
the first link.
And here you can get
instructions on what the
design goals are.
You can download the project.
And also if you want--
we're developing
this using GIT.
So you can GIT clone a
repository if you want, and
then just keep pulling
for updates.
OK, actually I'll start
with a demo.
Dev App Server 2, its goal is
basically to eventually
replace the development server
that we use for offline,
non-production Python
development and testing.
And here's a simple application
that I made.
Actually, I'll just start
by running it.
Here it is running in the
original development server.
So, Dev App Server, I will
run it on port 9000.
And then my App is on my
desktop, and it's called Perf.
I'll run that.
And it's running.
And then let me go here.
And what this does is it
just serves tiles.
The imagery is courtesy
of NASA.
And it's just tiles representing
the Earth.
Now, let me do the same thing
in a different window
using Version 2.
Hopefully that shell completion
is correct, even
though it looked wrong.
How are we doing?
Well, we're almost done.
And then in Version 2,
it's getting nervous
because of the demo.
Actually, that is very odd.
Let me switch back here.
I feel like a Microsoft
executive on
the stage right now.
Let me restart.
AMY: Do you want to just
play Steve Ballmer?
MATT: So it's experimental?
BRIAN: Yes, did I say
it was experimental?
OK.
Let's try again.
OK, I don't know why
this is happening.
This is the App.
It had Threadsafe
No set before.
Let me change that to Yes.
Do I have maybe just a network
connectivity problem?
That's possible, I suppose.
Let me try once more.
And then I'll just tell
you how awesome this
demo would have been.
OK.
I don't know why
that happened.
One of the goals of the project
is the new frontend is
multi-threaded.
You can see, compared to--
this is the current
development server.
I just hit Reload.
And you can see the performance
loading content.
And in Version 2, which I just
switched to, this is the
performance loading
the example app.
And you can see, version one,
if I switch back, it's still
not even half done before the
previous one is finished.
And just to give you an idea of
what the application looks
like, these image tiles are
being served, half of them are
being served, through
static content.
And the other half are being
served through a user-defined
application.
And the application is
completely trivial.
It's just sleep for 100
milliseconds to simulate doing
some sort of work and then just
open the image, read it,
and then write the response.
Interesting, I just noticed now
that this is not correct
for Windows.
Let me fix that.
We'll try and add
this to our demo
applications at some point.
We just have to check
the copyright
on that NASA imagery.
So, you can see one of the
advantages that we have in the
new development application
server is performance due to
this multi-threaded frontend.
We also have a nicer task
queue behavior, because
multiple tasks can execute
concurrently.
And they don't block user
requests when they're running.
The current development server
also has this problem where if
you URL fetch your own
application, it deadlocks.
That's because your application
is running.
It's single-threaded, so when
you then connect back to
yourself, that connect
back blocks
until the request finishes.
But, of course, the request will
never finish until the
URL fetch returns.
It also fixes some problems.
A few browsers, notably Opera,
have problems displaying
content from single-threaded web
servers, because they do
multiple fetches in parallel.
And they kind of get confused
if the fetches don't return.
In addition to this
multi-threaded frontend, we do
have a few other nice things.
We're aiming to have a
much higher fidelity.
We want to more accurately
reflect the production
environment.
So we do that by spawning
multiple
instances to handle requests.
We support thread safe.
You saw I turned that
on, and it magically
made everything work.
I don't know why that is.
But clearly thread safe actually
does something on
this development server.
We support warm-up requests.
The sandbox, which is the part
of the development server that
makes the security look like the
production run time, it's
a lot more robust in the
Version 2 run time.
And also we support multiple
library versions.
In the current development
server, we only will let you
use one version of webapp, even
though your library's
directive allows you to specify
different versions.
We fixed that in Dev
App Server 2.
By the way, if anyone is online
and has questions, feel
free to fire away.
AMY: Yeah, Anton
has joined us.
And please feel free to type in
the chat window or break in
if you have anything you'd
like to ask or discuss.
BRIAN: What else?
There's also this new project
we're doing on App Engine
called Servers.
We're not really ready to
disclose very much about that.
There was a tiny bit that
we talked about on
I/O talk this year.
Do you remember what talk it
was at the end of, Sam?
SAM: Not sure which talk
it was, but it was
one given by Troy.
BRIAN: Troy.
OK, so if you look on the Google
I/O site, look for Troy
and App Engine.
By look for, I mean, of course,
the search is App
Engine Google I/O Troy.
And you look at about the last
15 minutes of the talk, and
you'll hear a bit
about servers.
Servers are basically,
conceptually, they're in the
same space as backends, just
a way of running additional
functionality as part of the
same logical application.
So, one of the goals of the Dev
App Server 2 project is to
support that robustly in a way
that the current development
server does not provide the
equivalent support for backend.
So, for example, the Version 2
Development Server supports
background threads, what
else does it support?
Did Version 1 support H Start
and Stop requests?
SAM: I think it might have
Start but not Stop.
We'll have probably Shut
Down requests in V-2.
BRIAN: Yeah.
MATT: You need some kind of
multi-processing to support
servers or backends.
BRIAN: Yeah, in a logical way.
MATT: The old Dev App server,
the architecture couldn't have
supported any kind of ongoing
background requests or
background processing because
it's single-threaded.
BRIAN: Yeah, that's pretty
much what our goals are.
We're also just trying to do
as much cleanup as we can,
just support some little things
that make life better
for people.
For example, we're supporting
High Replication Datastore
exclusively.
And we have some parameters to
allow you to configure exactly
what consistency mode
you want for
High Replication Datastore.
It's a small thing, but
I think it's cool.
We package all of the data
files related to an
application, like the Datastore,
Blobstore in one
directory, which I
think is nice.
Can you guys think of anything
else that's kind
of small but cool?
Very sad.
AMY: And I can't remember if
you mentioned that it's
essentially open source, taking
contributions from
people who want to.
BRIAN: Yeah, so we took a fairly
different approach to
open sourcing Version 2 of
the development server.
If anyone else has looked at the
source for Version 1, you
can see we push the code maybe
once every month or two.
They don't include comments
or tests.
And there's no easy way for you
to produce patches or file
issues except through
the public App
Engine Issue Tracker.
We've changed all of those
things for Dev App Server 2.
The code is, I was going to
say well-commented, but
clearly that's a matter that
software engineers fight over.
I think it's well-commented.
AMY: Is it self-documented?
MATT: It has all the comments
that we can see.
BRIAN: We include
the unit tests.
So if you want to know--
some people have providing
feedback saying that--
From your perspective, it gives
you a chance to affect
our development trajectories.
So, people have already noted
that maybe some of the
dependencies that we have should
at least be documented
better, or they should warn you
appropriately if you don't
have those in place.
And we've already taken action
to address that, because right
now we have a small
pool of users.
And we're trying our best
to make them happy.
MATT: So, is there an issue
tracker on GitHub?
Are you using that?
BRIAN: Not on GitHub,
on Google Code.
MATT: Oh, OK, and is it the same
issue tracker that you
used for the rest
of App Engine?
BRIAN: No, it's not.
MATT: OK, so how do you find
that on Google Code?
Is there a link from GitHub?
BRIAN: No, all our code
is on Google Project.
So, once you've done your search
for Dev App Server 2,
you just click the
Issues link.
And then you can
file your bugs.
AMY: I think your laptop has
left the Hangout due to our
little reboot there.
If you want to join in.
BRIAN: I was just going to--
MATT: And, also, what's the
license for Dev App Server 2?
BRIAN: It's all Apache
licensed.
Join.
SAM: Whoops, [INAUDIBLE].
AMY: OK, so I'm not seeing any
questions yet on the moderator
from any of our viewing
audience.
And if you have a question and
you want to ask, if you go to
developers.google.com/live and
look for this event and click
on it, you should be
able to find the
moderator queue there.
We welcome your questions.
And you should also be able to
join from that event page if
you want to talk
to us directly.
Otherwise, I'll play audience
for a few minutes and ask
these guys a few
more questions.
Sorry, there's someone asking
can you hear us OK?
BRIAN: We can't hear
you at all.
AMY: No, unfortunately,
we can't.
MATT: We can't see them
in the Hangout either.
AMY: We had a little
bit of a glitch.
And our Hangout screen appeared
to reboot itself.
And the person who's asking
that question may
want to try to rejoin.
And then we see a question
from Anand.
Are there any new and
interesting features we expect
to see in Dev App Server 2?
BRIAN: Yes, well, as I said,
we're basically trying to
track features that are coming
up in App Engine itself.
Servers would be a big one.
But, obviously, the point of the
development server is to
emulate what happens
in production.
So, obviously, we're not going
to add any features that
aren't going to be available
when you actually deploy your
application.
Fidelity, I guess, would
be our better feature.
And as I said, we're supporting
background threads,
warm-up requests, better
sandboxing, better library
version support.
MATT: Some of the really tiny
things that have come up just
from the process of porting
over the code to Dev App
Server 2, just discovering
little things that were wrong
like, for example, HTTP
headers being
sent exactly the same.
We cleaned up all that.
Just lots of small things that
will make it closer to
production.
BRIAN: Yeah, exactly.
MATT: One of the things that's
still a problem, I think, with
Dev App Server 2 that we may be
working towards improving
is that a lot of the libraries,
you need to bring
your own version
of the library.
Can we talk about--
this is not in the current
version of Dev App Server 2.
You still need to bring your own
version of libraries like
LXML and some of
the other ones.
I think at least the
architecture will perhaps
allow this to be fixed.
BRIAN: Yeah, I mean adding the
dependencies as part of the
packaging is definitely
something we'd like to do in
the future.
Did the person who asked
whether they--
I hope, Anand, that answers
your question.
The other person who we couldn't
hear, could you type
in your question, or your
feedback, or whatever you
wanted to say?
AMY: I see Bryce has
just joined us.
Hi, Bryce.
If you want to type any
questions into the chat or
turn on your audio,
you're welcome to.
BRIAN: Well, we don't know if we
can actually hear people if
they turn on their audio.
MATT: So far we're just seeing
black or profile pictures.
BRIAN: We're all software
engineers.
But at home we all have 8:00
blinking on our VCRs.
AMY: So, Bryce is typing
something.
That's great.
He says he's in a busy room.
He does have to have
his A/V on.
Very good point.
I have a question to ask.
I notice that in the command
line options for Dev App
Server 2 the High Replication
flag is gone.
And there's a Consistency
flag.
Do you guys want to say a
little more about that?
It looks like an improvement
to your model.
BRIAN: Sure, there's no support
for emulating the old
master-slave Datastore anymore
since it's been deprecated
for, how long?
Instead, what the flag does
is control exactly how the
consistency works in
High Replication.
The default is time-based.
Let me just take a half a step
back and explain how High
Replication works at the
most trivial level.
If you do a Put in the
Datastore, and then you do a
Query which should find
that Put-- and it's
not an Ancestor Query--
then it's possible that you
won't see the data you just
Put, because the data hasn't
replicated to the instance
that the Query is running on.
So, our defaults, this slide
that you were mentioning, by
default it emulates that
behavior where the probability
of a Put appearing in a Query
result is proportional to the
time that's passed since you
added it to the Datastore.
AMY: And that's good,
because it didn't
used to be the default.
It used to be--
BRIAN: Master-slave
was the default.
And this, actually, is the
most consistent with how
production App Engine works.
The longer you wait, the more
likely that entity you Put
will appear in Query results.
We also have another mode
which is purely
probability-based,
not time-based.
And this is actually pretty good
for testing correctness.
The problem with the time-based
model, if you do a
Put, and then you do a Request
two seconds later, you'll
almost always see that the Put
you do appears in the results.
Because two seconds means
it's highly likely to
appear in the results.
The random one just assigns a
probability, whether every
query increases the probability
that you'll see a
particular entity in it.
That means you can hit refresh
in your browser, or whatever
triggers a query, and even if
there was a time delay there,
you might not see the results.
That's good for stress testing
your correctness.
And there is a final mode, which
is just force things to
be consistent.
So, as soon as you
do a Put, you're
guaranteed to see the results.
And the only good reason to
use that is if you have a
test, and you're using the
development server as part of
that, and you just
need determinism.
We use that ourselves for
some of our tests.
Because the tests would
be flaky if it had
non-deterministic aspects.
AMY: And also, perhaps, just for
debugging if you want to
rule out that it's--
BRIAN: Oh, yeah, if you
had a sequencing
problem, and you wanted--
yeah, then forcing a particular
ordering would be useful.
Yeah, that's true.
AMY: Just checking if we had any
more moderator questions.
No moderator questions?
Oh, there is one.
All right, well this is not
quite on the topic of the Dev
App Server, but it's one that
everyone would be interested
in discussing, I think.
So, we'll diverge briefly.
Do you think it's worth
learning Go?
Currently using Python as
my primary language.
I would say, emphatically,
yes.
Go is an excellent language.
And it's clean and beautiful.
And you will have a lot
of fun learning it.
Would you guys like to
contribute to that?
BRIAN: Well, as always, spinning
things back toward
something at least vaguely
Dev App Server 2 related,
currently backends allow you
to write a single logical
application using versions,
in general.
There's a trick where you can
deploy an application with one
version, and then change the run
time and the version and
deploy it again.
So, now, serving under different
domains like version
number dot your app dot appspot
dot com, you can have
code running in different
languages.
So, if you have Python code that
might have a performance
hot spot, and you want to
code it in Go, which is
significantly faster, then you
can use this approach.
When Servers are released, then
they'll be a much more
convenient way of structuring
your applications like this.
I'm a Python guy.
But it never hurts to learn
another language.
And I think Go complements
Python quite nicely.
MATT: So, does the Dev App
Server 2, do you plan to
support Go?
BRIAN: Absolutely.
You'll be able to run--
right now, basically the same
development server is used to
run Python apps and Go apps.
And in Dev App Server 2, it will
be possible to write an
application that has both Go and
Python components as part
of the same logical
application.
MATT: And I suppose it would
be remiss of me not to ask,
what about Java?
To put some context on it, if
you look in the current SDKE,
you'll find that the Go
development server is largely
based on the Python one.
Whereas the Java one is
completely separate and
written in Java.
I'm asking the hard question.
It's much harder to integrate.
BRIAN: Your colleagues are
always the worst critics.
It would be nice to
support that.
The big difference is in
culture, I think, between
Python and Java.
In Python and Go, we don't
really have a good ID story,
debugging story.
Python doesn't really have a
good debugging story because,
for whatever reason, Python
developers tend not to use
things like debuggers.
And the ID space is--
MATT: We don't have bugs.
BRIAN: And the ID space
is heavily fragmented.
Sam uses VIM.
Well, I'm--
MATT: We all use VIM, come on.
BRIAN: Well, I use VIM, too.
I've been playing
with Sublime.
SAM: You pretend
not to use VIM.
AMY: I use Sublime.
BRIAN: And I was using
Komodo before.
But people have different
expectations for tool support
versus Java people, where
they expect there's--
well, I was going to say there's
Eclipse and IntelliJ.
And really for open
source stuff,
there's really just Eclipse.
And Java developers expect a
very polished experience as
far as being able to invoke
their code directly from the
IDE to be able to set break
points and debug and just
doing that integration work.
We definitely should do it.
But there's a lot of open
questions on how we would make
that work, especially if you
have a mixed Python Java app,
and you hit run in Eclipse,
what does that mean?
How should that work?
MATT: To answer the question,
yeah, it's good if you want to
use Go and mix that with Python,
you'll have a much
better experience on the
Dev App Server 2.
AMY: In the future it will
be easier to mix them.
MATT: And Anand says VIM FTW.
AMY: So, let me ask you
guys another question.
Say a little more about the
multiple instance support,
which seems really cool, maybe
something that as people tune
in and out of this broadcast,
they might not have heard so
much about.
BRIAN: Sam, you haven't
answered a
question yet, go for it.
SAM: OK, in Dev App Server 1
we have a single instance
unless you use backends,
which will do one
instance per backend.
But in Dev App Server 2, we
support much more production
like instances where we will
start up new instances in
response to traffic, kind of
like production does, but not
really the same algorithm as
production, though it looks
clever anyway.
BRIAN: So, say I had a handler
that was just Sleep Five
Seconds and then Print
Hello World.
You're saying in Dev App Server
1 if I did that in five
separate tabs on my browser,
I triggered them one after
another, it would take 25
seconds to see their result in
the [INAUDIBLE]?
SAM: Yes, exactly.
BRIAN: And in Dev App Server
2, it would make--
what would happen?
SAM: Well, it depends if you
have Thread Safe On or Off.
BRIAN: OK, let's say I
have Thread Safe Off.
MATT: He's like, it doesn't
work at all if you
have Thread Safe Off.
SAM: Well, on other computers,
it won't, fine.
If you have Thread Safe Off,
then after a short time, based
on some min wait time or
something, it will spin up new
instances, which will then
serve the requests.
You can only get five seconds.
MATT: So, the console in Dev
App Server 2, which is--
BRIAN: Sadly, there's not.
There's a lot of code motion.
We add stuff.
We remove stuff.
MATT: Then what's left
of [INAUDIBLE]?
BRIAN: We need to add some sort
of UI like production to
visualize what instances
are getting created.
And we add that UI and make some
changes to how instances
are handled.
The UI ends up breaking.
We remove it.
We re-add it working.
And then the cycle repeats.
SAM: The good news is if you put
Debugging Prints On, then
you'll see Starting Instance
One, Stopping Instance One,
Starting Instance Two, when
you start them up.
BRIAN: I think you also get--
there's some debugging
statements that will show when
it's handling a request, like
if you have Thread Safe On,
how many requests the
instances are already handling.
So, you can see how much
concurrency you're getting.
So Amy is checking something.
AMY: I'm checking the moderator
queue again.
We have no more questions.
If anyone is watching and has
questions, I really would
suggest you jump on the queue.
Because this is a relatively
rare opportunity to talk to
the people who are working on
something you use every day
and ask them about it.
So we have a question from
Bryce coming in, I think.
MATT: See, the pressure is on
as soon as you start typing.
AMY: We're waiting
in suspense.
BRIAN: Can you juggle, Matt?
MATT: Three balls.
We don't have any
here, though.
BRIAN: We're the only Googlers
on the App Engine team that
can't juggle and entertain
people.
MATT: I thought Peter was
getting everyone to
learn how to juggle.
SAM: He even got to me.
BRIAN: I tried.
MATT: Well, when you show up
for work, there's juggling
balls on the desk.
Learn how to juggle.
AMY: Well, we may have run out
of audience questions.
Anand, do you have any more
questions you would like to
ask the group?
Oh, I think Bryce is still
typing, actually.
BRIAN: So, while the typing is
happening, I'll just add we're
trying to be responsive
to people's feedback.
As I say, this is a
great opportunity.
At this point, we're still at
early stage for you to be able
to affect the direction of the
project, or at least make sure
that it doesn't have bugs or
missing features that will
affect you.
So I would strongly encourage
you, if you use the
Development Server as part of
your development process, then
play with the experimental
server,
file bugs, ask questions.
Even if you don't want to look
at it now, if there's big
limitations in the current
development server, then let
us now to make sure that we
don't have the same kind of
problems in Version 2.
AMY: And sort of apropos of
that, Bryce asks, is Dev App 2
a total rewrite?
I'm wondering if perhaps some
of the Dev App Server 1 bugs
were carried over.
And he mentions, particularly,
two issues that I'll look up.
Issue 8383 is the one
where changes to .py
files are not detected.
And Issue 7717 is the one in
Windows where SQLite fails to
write files due to using the
Windows folder Temp.
BRIAN: So that kind of bug
we don't carry over.
That file detection bug
should only be in that
release that was in--
the next release of the Dev
App Server will fix that.
But we don't have that bug.
SAM: There's a completely new
strategy for file changes.
BRIAN: Right, it's lighter
weight in the sense that it
takes less resources
on your computer
to detect file changes.
MATT: To go to the first part
of the question though, I
think that a lot of the Dev App
Server 1 code was carried
over, particularly the stubs,
all of the API stubs, the
DataStore, memcache, URL
fetch, and so on.
That has been tweaked
a little bit.
We made a Thread Safe,
for example.
But it's mostly carried over.
The new part is the shell around
it that manages the
instances and manages
running Python code
and importing modules.
What percentage would
you say is new?
BRIAN: Well, except for
the APIs, probably
90% of it is new.
We also do the app.yaml
parsing is the same.
But most of it is new.
And the second part, the second
question, I actually
don't know about the--
I know what bug you're talking
about, about creating SQLite
in the directory.
And to be honest, I haven't
tested that.
But I will now.
AMY: And Bryce comments, with
stubs carried over, there's a
good chance that bug
still exists.
So, we'll check on it.
SAM: On Windows,
the SQLite one.
BRIAN: But isn't it, it
only occurs if you
don't run as admin.
And I think I do
on my machine.
SAM: Run as admin?
BRIAN: Oh, is that?
I'm not really a Windows--
SAM: --admin anymore.
BRIAN: Oh, really?
MATT: Yeah, they cleaned up.
BRIAN: I'm not really much
of a Windows guy.
I assume my Windows 7 box is
basically the same as my
Windows 2000 box.
I haven't seen that bug.
AMY: We'll make a
note to do it.
BRIAN: We'll make a note
to look into it.
MATT: I think the current
Windows strategy is don't run
as admin unless a program
breaks, and then run as admin.
AMY: We have another question
from the moderator.
Would it be possible to see
server side JavaScript for App
Engine Development, something
like Node.js?
For this one, I hope everyone
can hear me.
I'm a little further
away from the mic.
Our stock answer is, well, we
don't really comment on things
that aren't specifically
on the roadmap.
But we're definitely aware that
people are interested in
something like that.
And there's probably
an external
issue requesting that.
So, please go and star it.
I'm almost certain there is.
And if there's not, you
can create one.
MATT: There is one.
AMY: Yes, the more stars
the better on
these kinds of requests.
Externally, that's very
helpful to us.
MATT: I think Bryce said
something else.
AMY: Yes, Bryce says, admin
can write to Windows.
But regular users can not.
This bug does not exist if you
use an earlier version of
Python than 2.7.
BRIAN: Oh, interesting.
AMY: Yeah, that is
interesting.
Thanks for all the information
on that.
MATT: Thanks, Bryce.
BRIAN: It would actually be
really helpful if you--
we only support the SQLite
stub, not the
pickle-based stub.
If you're willing to give us a
hand, Bryce, if you downloaded
the Dev App Server 2 and just
run whatever application is
giving you problems with V1--
We'll look into it
independently.
But the best way to ensure that
we fix it for you is if
you tell us it's broken for you,
then we'll work to make
sure it's fixed for you.
SAM: I don't think we actually
said that this only supports
the Python 2.7 runtime.
BRIAN: Right.
SAM: We're not actually
supporting Python 2.5.
AMY: For the experimental
Dev App Server.
BRIAN: Yeah.
So, you found this link?
Optimizing your Google App
Engine App is the talk that
mentioned Servers at the end.
AMY: It's a Google I/O talk.
BRIAN: If you look at Google
I/O 2012, Optimizing Your
Google App Engine App, and then
look at about the last 15
minutes, it'll talk a
bit about Servers.
And the content before
that is good, too.
MATT: Do not skip.
AMY: OK, well, I think we don't
have any more questions.
So, I think we'll wrap
it up at that.
BRIAN: For everyone who is
watching, thanks very
much for tuning in.
And we'll thank you even more if
you give us feedback on Dev
App Server 2.
AMY: Yes, we look forward to
having you play around a bit.
And you mentioned that there was
a discussion group for it.
BRIAN: There is a discussion
group.
And if you go to the Google
Project page, it's all linked
from there.
AMY: Thanks very much for
watching, everyone.
See you next time.
BRIAN: Bye.
MATT: Bye.